that is very character loyal
but uh yeah we'll definitely we'll see
they're coming up right now
yeah all right we got the expected
characters for both these players
after freaks uh
cherry berry mango playing chin versus
uh africa fix moyo
team kill
man you know i've seen that af there all
night i didn't realize it was africa
freaks even though i've seen africa
freezing on the bracket the entire time
i just see a brain
you know
uh but here we go cbm moyo gin and geese
howard hammerhead stage game one
all right all right
oh with the final fantasy stage
this might be amusing round
it might be but you know probably not if
you're losing it it depends
great spacing dabs there
yeah
oh man i feel like geese howard is one
of these characters where if you have a
character that can pair his follow-ups
uh the prairie can become really
effective against them
yeah we'll see if cbm
uh does that how are you posting match
from general
man he loves that kind of swing oh boy
yeah
get off me twice
okay
slight lead here
poking away so far no no big damage yet
yeah but these pokes are adding up right
he's got over half life yeah
yeah oh tried and electric there that
forward four keeping him out boyle
pushing into the wall
and that's what that round was
culminating to basically uh round two
yeah
cotton oil coming in with the hook fist
finish the round and that's one of my
favorite things about cbm's gin right
like he loves that electric yeah he
loves landing it counts i love it yeah
oh yeah yeah
there it is
yeah we'll carry here
wow look at this round it's just
down back forward just so fast
two rounds up carefully mango
you know have a slow start come back
later
yeah we've definitely seen that playing
out
molly
it wasn't even the duck it was this
dance transition the one he goes
backwards
[Music]
[Music]
literally jabbing him down
yeah oh the counter hit
pour and
cherry very mango tying it up in life
[Music]
still a big lead so you don't have to do
anything crazy
oh my god oh
man
how many got this is that for this game
wait wait it's not done yet it's not
done yet
yeah
he's looking at sidestep you know
oh it's never over until it's over yeah
yo this is cbm's battle of stage for
comebacks bro yeah this is not the same
cpf and 2d characters let me tell you oh
yeah yeah yeah
yeah the stage
music it brings back the other memory
oh
the parry
good chunk of damage and the wall
position
[Music]
another big lead for cbm
this time
not a full bar yet but it's gonna build
up there oh man he's gonna have the full
meter before he enters around nice
little parry yeah
here you go
but yeah i mean boyle so dangerous at
any moment he has a bar now
oh gosh oh
damn corner again
it should be good that was
that was nice
that hell sleep was nice he just like
kind of got up and he's just like yeah
i'm gonna help sleep now like you're not
gonna expect this just got up run up
he'll sweep and yeah that was i was the
round in that game so
good stuff
yeah cbm uh definitely doesn't use that
hell sweep a lot right so it's a little
bit less predictable when he does it
however i also feel like he's only using
it and around situation where it's going
to kill he needs to come back you know
like i feel like that's yeah the
desperation gin tactic of choice you
know it's like i'm behind i need
something
it's going to be a hell sweep you know
like that's the one they always seem to
go to
um but so far it's working out right and
man moyle is so scary anytime he's alive
and he's got meter to work with yeah you
have to be scared you know if you're
back to the wall especially scared uh
and even with geese now his walker is so
good that if the wall's not near you
should still be scared so if you can't
even blame him for losing that round but
moyle he's prepared to come back in so
many different ways uh that you got to
be as cautious as can be basically but
uh so far so good cbm holding on
got the first game needs to get one more
to stay in the tournament move on to top
four
uh small trying to get two to get on
there but
it's uh it looks pretty good for cbm
right now
yeah
yeah he's he's looking
pretty comfortable but i mean
we've seen moyle you know just
game two just uh just really turn it on
so uh this could be a very different
uh
game that we're going into but um
yeah we'll see round one
fight all right here we go abandoned
temple gonna be the stage
[Music]
oh and we saw how many of those we
landed
in that first game yeah good punish up
close
looking pretty loose right now yeah
exactly
gotta be feeling yourself to do those
[Music]
oh man
yeah didn't kill though it doesn't
matter down three closes out but yeah
the timing was perfect he went up he
pauses like
now you can hit a button boom electric
yeah that was beautiful
double back down
what is the success rate on these
electrics
uh
high very very high yeah very very high
oh okay back to one to
take that round already two rounds
cherry berry mango
this is boiled he just he just
eliminated me
and cherry berry mango here right
looking to know around he didn't have an
electron
yeah oh he got the step though
perfect combos always
yeah
so
optimal uh-oh
[Music]
is that a life deficit but he's
not at a round deficit he has two rounds
up
yeah and this is not enough of a life
deficit now he's got rage as well he can
definitely come back with one big
counterhead
one counter electric or one forward four
count rate
yeah but now he's got very little to
work with yeah
yeah while playing it compact
making sure that he gets that round
a lot of just simple jabs
oh yes again
yeah
what were you talking about high success
rate uh electrics
yes yeah i don't know what the cbm
stands for it's probably cherry mango
but it's like some high cbs cram you
know boom the bounce
look at this
and that he's out of here
you win
cherry berry
mango
very nice very nicely done cbm moving
into the top four here uh that is pretty
impressive dude you know he looked a
little shaky when we saw him earlier on
the winning side of the bracket but
right there looking fantastic and uh top
four finisher that's fantastic boy you
know he just i don't know what it was he
just kept on getting hit by electrics
like i think that was really the story
that entire set uh if somehow he didn't
get hit by 10 electrics he probably
would have won but when you get hit by
10 elections in trouble
yeah
yeah
oh yeah exactly like it's just all the
electors are landing and this was the
best thing moyle got started right he
got to a side there and that that's
where a lot of his successes come
actually looking back at his matches he
gets a clutch side step into like the
full combo but
these electrics all adding up full
damage there cherry berry mango 2-0 over
the man who just took out knee so well
played uh but cbm into the top four here
impressive stuff congrats yeah
yeah
yeah just uh you know cbm is uh you know
he's been known for his ford fours uh a
lot as well too right but we didn't see
too much of that in that last game i
mean he got a couple counter hits here
and there it was a that was definitely
like a an electric gin
that we saw 100 yeah it's always hype
yeah yeah that's my favorite kind of
thing you know like the fourth oh yeah
that's kind of what
but
yeah that's beautiful right that's what
we want to see
uh see